hi guys in this video I'm going to talk
about insulin and lean muscle mass now
some people are trying to build more
muscle mass and they're not able to do
it and this is why and I'm going to just
show you help you understand what's
going on at the cellular level this is a
muscle cell right here and there's
several key pieces of the puzzle that
we're going to talk about number one it
takes insulin to act as a key to unlock
the door of the cells to allow the amino
acids to go into the cell and convert
the amino acids to skeletal muscle
protein so we need insulin to make
muscle protein that is true okay the
problem is that most people don't
understand what insulin resistance is
when you have insulin resistance which
is a pre-diabetic State or you're a
diabetic type 2 you have a situation
where you have lots of insulin but it's
resistance it's not working in the body
so you basically have a deficiency of
insulin with insulin resistance okay
so you don't have any more unlocking of
any door there boy
thereby starving off the amino acids
from the cell so this idea that oh I
need more insulin so I'm gonna have more
carbs to allow more amino acid to go in
there all you're gonna do is are going
to create a resistance and you're gonna
block these amino acids from going in
the cell and B and being converted in a
muscle tissue now here's the other point
you want to know it only your body only
needs a very small amount of sugar in
the system small amount of sugar and in
a moderate amount of insulin which
basically is a hundred milligrams per
deciliter of insulin and what does that
mean that's only one teaspoon per gallon
and a half of blood that is so small an
average person has 21 teaspoons of sugar
every single day so we need a very very
small of carbs so when you do carbo
loading you increase a lot of sugar
you're basically shutting down the even
insulin it's an insolence ability to
work okay so we need some insulin but we
don't need to trigger it by carbs we
don't need to increase it
by taking more sugar at all we don't
want to do that just what we want to do
is we want to look at these other
factors you can actually have a normal
insulin without having any carbs okay
and just your body can make sugar your
body can make normal insulin if it
doesn't have too much too much sugar so
it also takes exercise to stimulate a
hormone called growth hormone that then
we'll make the amino acids convert to
muscle protein as well so we need this
hormone called growth hormone that
triggers this process so we need normal
insulin growth hormone we need to
trigger to make this happen
so if you want to build muscle mass you
have to do something you have to work
your body so growth hormone is triggered
by hardcore exercise high intensity
exercise full body boo compound
resistant training with lots of rest if
you over trained you'll actually never
allow the recovery because exercise
basically breaks down the muscle and
it's the recovery that actually builds
the muscle through growth hormone but
you got a you got to stimulate the
muscle and then you have to let it heal
through the sleep that's why the deep
sleep is key if you don't have enough
sleep you're not going to build muscle
more sleep more muscle mass you need
moderate amount of protein if you do
higher amounts of protein like lots of
protein you can actually Jam up the
liver and you can also trigger insulin
that will create insulin resistance so
you need a little bit you don't need a
lot you need high quality fish is very
high quality amino acids some people do
whey protein I'm not against that but
the problem it's so lean it doesn't have
the normal fats in it that you also need
to buffer some of the insulin response
what triggers insulin a lot more than
other proteins is low fat whey protein
it's low fat and it will spike insulin
so if you're gonna consume way add some
fat to it maybe coconut oil or something
like that so we also we need sodium and
potassium the pump the window the door
that this key unlocks is called the
sodium potassium pump
so you have these minerals that exchange
that allow this little transport of
protein to go through and also vitamins
and minerals and glucose but we need
this pump so that means that if you're
not consuming enough sodium it won't
work but more chances are you're not
consuming enough potassium you need way
more potassium than sodium sodium is 10
- 10 you pi need like a half a teaspoon
of sodium per day but you need 4700
milligrams of potassium every day to get
your normal requirement that's like 7 to
10 cups of vegetables you can take it as
a supplement but the supplements come in
like 99 milligrams you need 4700 so you
can get in a powder or electrolyte blend
but the point is that you need these two
minerals to allow me no acids to go in
the cell because that requires the pump
to be activated and work correctly so
just sometimes by fixing this ratio of
minerals you can get more lean body mass
because you'll get more entry in fact
the sodium potassium actually also will
fix insulin resistance as well right so
I just wanted to kind of break down this
problem the little pieces to see where
maybe you might need to strengthen an
area versus another area put your
comments below thanks for watching
press it forget it forget it I'm done
press the subscribe button and I will
keep you updated on the future of events